live local now Clark County School
police seizing more than a Dozen guns
some loaded thanks for joining us here
at five I'm David charns and I'm Denise
Valdez that's according to data 8 news
now just obtained from the district now
this Revelation comes at a time where
Clark County schools are considering
introducing metal detectors when school
returns in August 8 news now education
reporter Joshua peguero here to show us
what he found out Joshua David Denise it
took us four months to get this data
here we have the total number of guns
school policies during the 2021-2022
school year some were on campus so those
were not out of the 60 guns 20 had a
magazine or were loaded but for school
police either one is taken seriously
we treat every firearm as being real and
as being loaded and we we look at that
situation where somebody could
potentially lose their life and that's
the last thing that we want especially
if the school was a place where everyone
should be safe ccsdpd detective Matthew
Caldwell stresses that parents need to
secure their weapons at least five of
the gun school police confiscated were
armed one handgun seized last March had
one round in the chamber plus 14 rounds
in a magazine and you think about
um how do you stop things from happening
you're not always going to get a phone
call or a tip that somebody might have a
weapon
um you need proactive policing as well
some of the proactive measures include
the Clark County School District
announcing its planning to add metal
detectors at some high schools most of
the Firearms seized were handguns Pastor
Troy Martinez is the founder of dads in
schools some of our volunteers have been
on campus when large groups get agitated
ready to fight but because our
volunteers are right in the middle the
fight never takes place it's a program
that places volunteers at schools across
the valley Martinez says he's looking to
place at least two volunteers at each
school he adds that keeping kids and
staff safe must be a community-run
effort I know for a fact that young
people bring a gun to school because
they're afraid and if we reduce the fear
we'll reduce guns at schools
now as you can see with this data three
ghost guns were confiscated by ccsdpd
these are guns that don't have a serial
number and a harder to track again out
of the 60 guns police recovered at least
five were loaded Denise